welcome back everybody let's head to
nevada coin mart where you can sell your
jewelry and coin safely
hi welcome to nevada coin mark come in
let me show you around
shoes shirt face mask required as soon
as you walk in
we have the mask for you and the hand
sanitizer
we're always looking out for you we have
the security checkpoint
he's going to ask you say hi how can you
help you and you're going to say what
you'd like to do let me continue the
tour
over here i am the main sponsor for the
injured police officers fund that's the
ipof
the most wonderful organization for all
the police in all of the whole entire
state of nevada
the only thing that i buy sell and trade
coins paper currency bullion
any type of products like this here we
have the spot price
of gold silver platinum and palladium
the on display for you
here's all the coins and currency that
we do sell
buy sell and trade let me tell you the
other thing that i got for you
i got booth nine what's booth nine
that's where we take care of
larger items you know why because i buy
silver plate
i buy sterling silver flatware we do
larger items here back here this is part
of my
six privacy windows everything is done
with
social distancing for you no one is
going to be near you
and we're here to do business let me
tell you the other fun thing i got for
you
this is the most beautiful store so when
you come in
we're going to look at what you have
we're going to evaluate it
we're going to make sure that we give
you the very best price my name is neil
sachmary
my name is on the building let me tell
you this
when you want to sell you want to go to
the number one guy in las vegas
gold silver costume jewelry coins paper
currency
bullion silver and turquoise jewelry
did i tell you that i love costume
jewelry
i want to sort your jewelry box for free
i want to buy your entire coin
collection
all you need to do is get up get out of
bed
get to the corner of jones in flamingo
this is my only location
so all you need to do is get here
because i'm going to be waiting for you
to have cash in hand if you want to get
paid
and you want to get paid the most value
for what you have there's
only one place to go in las vegas one
neil sac mary nevada coin mark on the
corner of jones and flamingo
gold silver costume jewelry coins paper
currency
i want to buy what you have i want to
buy and look at
all your costume jewelry your estate
jewelry
your vintage jewelry maybe you have
something that's been passed down
maybe you don't know the value i offer
free verbal appraisals
all you need to do is come down and see
me i'm waiting for you
right now give them a call that number
is right there on your screen or just
visit neilbuys.com we'll be right back